local now
right now there is one big question who
was in the barrel boaters making a
disturbing discovery along the shore of
lake mead
tonight we are learning more about how
long this person could have been in the
lake concealed now for years good
evening to you thank you for joining us
at six i'm brian loftis i'm denise
valdez our eight news now i-team broke
this story last night now the i-team
first to tell you that the body was
likely under water for decades the
receding water revealing more than just
new beach our david charns is near
hemingway harbor talking to
investigators
where i'm standing today was underwater
40 years ago about the time that police
believe the person found in this barrel
died today there are no signs of that
barrel as investigators tried to figure
out just who this was
it's a troubling side effect of climate
change as lake mead dries up the
so-called secrets here are being
revealed we heard a woman scream
from
the side of the beach and then my
husband went over to obviously see what
was wrong shawna hollister was returning
to hemingway harbor when she saw the
disturbing discovery she spoke to eight
news now on the phone and then he
realized there was a body there and a
barrel what do you make of this
it's a unique homicide investigation las
vegas metro police homicide lieutenant
ray spencer says teams have recovered
remains in the lake before but never
like this even identifying the person is
going to be an extensive challenge at
this point a challenge because evidence
in that barrel puts the time frame of
this person's death in the 1980s spencer
says police are reaching out to
scientists at unlv to give them a better
idea of just how long the oil container
was in the water because originally the
barrel we believe was fully intact so
for it to have eroded we're trying to
determine how long they were down
under the water level as for who was in
the barrel that could take a while it's
heartbreaking
to see that that's somebody's loved one
that's out there so
i mean i hope they get justice or
somebody finds out at least who it is
and as the lake continues to recede
spencer says similar cases could come to
the surface
i would say there's a very good chance
as the water level drops that we are
going to find you know additional human
remains investigators say they know how
this person died but they're not telling
us only the killer would know that they
add it will take several months to
figure out just who this person is along
lake mead i'm david charns live local
now
metro police asking us to remind you any
tip can be submitted anonymously through
crime stoppers that number in their
website right there on your screen crime
stoppers offers a reward for information
that leads to a conviction